[Music]
taking you to the white house let's
listen into joe biden best possible
terms
low tariffs few barriers trade and the
highest possible imports allowed
in the united states we call this
permanent normal trade relations pntr
but it's the same thing
revoking pntr for russia is going to
make it harder for russia to do business
with the united states
and doing it in unison with other
nations and make up half of the global
economy will be another crushing blow to
the russian economy it's already
suffering very badly from our sanctions
and i want to thank speaker pelosi
leader mccarthy leader schumer and
mcconnell and senators wyden and crapo
representative neil and brady for their
bipartisan leadership on this in the
congress
i would like to offer a special thanks
to speaker pelosi who's been a strong
advocate for for revoking pntr and who
agreed to hold off on that in the house
until
i could line up all of our key allies to
keep us in complete unison unity among
our allies is critically important as
you all know and from my perspective at
least
many issues divide us in washington but
standing for democracy in ukraine
pushing russia's aggression should not
be one of those issues
the free world is coming together to
confront putin
our two parties here at home are leading
the way
and with that bipartisan cooperation i'm
looking forward to signing the law
the bill revoking pntr
which is again most people think of it
as most favored nation status
we're also taking a further step
abandoning imports of goods from several
signature sectors of the russian economy
including seafoods vodka and diamonds
and we're going to continue to squeeze
putin
the g7 will seek to deny russia the
ability to borrow from leading
multinational institutions such as the
international monetary fund and the
world bank
putin is an aggressor he is the
aggressor and putin must pay the price
he cannot pursue a war that threatens
the very foundations which he's doing
the very foundations of international
peace and stability and then ask for
financial help from the international
community
the g7 is also stepping up pressure on
corrupt russian billionaires we're
adding new names to the list of
oligarchs and their families that were
targeted and we're increasing
coordination among the g7 countries to
target and capture their ill-begotten
gains
they support putin they steal from the
russian people
and they seek to hide their money in our
countries
they're part of that kleptocracy that
exists in moscow and they must share in
the pain
of these sanctions
and
while we're going after these uh
sue their super yachts and their
vacation homes and worth hundreds of
millions millions of dollars
we're also going to make it harder for
them to buy high-end products
manufactured in our country we're
banning the export of luxury luxury
goods to russia
they're also the latest steps we're
taking but
they're not the last steps we're going
to take and as i said at the beginning
of all these steps we're going to hit
putin harder because the united states
and our closest allies and partners are
acting in unison
the totality of our sanctions and export
controls is crushing the russian economy
ruble has lost more than half its value
they tell me it takes about
200 rubles to equal one dollar these
days moscow stock exchange has been
closed
for fully for two weeks because they
know the moment it opens it will
probably collapse
credit rating agencies has downgraded
russia's government to junk status
its economy to junk status
the list of businesses international
corporations leaving russia is growing
by the day
we're also continuing to close uh
corporations with allies and partners to
make sure that those close cooperation
we continue to have the ukrainian people
are are able to defend their own nation
the united states has sent more than one
billion dollars in security assistance
to ukraine over the last year
including anti-armor and anti-air
capabilities taking out tanks and planes
and helicopters
with new shipments arriving every day
we the united states are also
facilitating significant shipments of
security assistance from our allies and
partners to ukraine
and the humanitarian front we're working
closely with the un and humanitarian
organizations to support the people of
ukraine who have been displaced by the
violence in ukraine providing we're
providing tens of thousands of tons of
human supplies are you humanitarian
supplies
food water medicines coming by a truck
and train every single day
yesterday in poland vice president
harris harris announced an additional 53
million dollars in additional
humanitarian support to ukraine
that brings the total humanitarian
assistance to 107 million dollars in
just two weeks
we've joined this effort by more with
more than 30 other countries for
providing hundreds of millions more
and last night
under great credit the congress passed a
bipartisan spending bill
that included an additional 13.6
billion dollars and new assistance to
the ukrainian people
i look forward to signing that
immediately
i also want to be clear though
we will make sure ukraine has weapons to
defend against an invading russian force
we will we will send money and food and
aid to save the ukrainian people
and i will welcome ukrainian refugees we
should welcome them here with open arms
if they need access
and we're going to provide more support
for ukraine we're going to continue to
stand together with our allies in europe
and send unmistakable message
we'll defend every single inch of nato
territory of the full might of the
united and galvanized nato
we will not fight a war against russia
in ukraine
direct confrontation between nato
and russia is world war iii
something we must strive to prevent
but we already know putin's war against
ukraine will never be a victory
he hoped to dominate ukraine without a
fight he failed he helped to fracture
european resolve he failed helped to
weaken the transatlantic alliance he
failed helped to split apart american
democracies in terms of our positions he
failed
the american people are united the world
is united and we stand with the people
of ukraine we will not let autocrats and
would-be emperors dictate the direction
of the world
democracies are rising to meet this
moment
rallying the world to the side of peace
and the side of security
we're showing our strength and we will
not falter
god bless all of you god bless ukraine
and god bless our troops
[Music]
your white house has said that that
russia may use chemical weapons or
create a false flag operation to use
them what evidence have you seen showing
that and would the u.s have a military
response if putin does launch a chemical
weapons attack i'm not going to speak
about the intelligence but but uh russia
would pay a severe price to use
chemicals
the world is united we will not let
autocrats dictate to the world the
warning there from the u.s president joe
biden also vowing his words that we will
not fault her as he went through the
list as he sees it of
of objectives
which the u.s and its allies have
achieved in sanctioning russia
as well as the list as he sees of
failures that the the russians have
failed to achieve through the conflict
in ukraine let's bring in kimberly
halcott she's at the white house
listening into that
um kimberly very clear their message
from the u.s president
that
they are making progress through these
sanctions that seems to be
the message which the u.s president is
trying to get out there is that they are
making progress against the russian
offensive
yeah uh the u.s president certainly is
delivering that message you have to
remember that this is a message of the
west that is in conflict with russia so
certainly it is going to have bias
and we have to keep that in mind that
this is u.s rhetoric in contrast with
russian rhetoric uh having said that uh
and i should point out the reason i've
got my ear plugged right now is that
i've got marine one in the background
and it is very loud in fact it was very
loud throughout much of the president's
speech so it was difficult to hear
but what i can tell you and what we did
know about this is that it was
anticipated and certainly this is the
latest in a series of actions
by the u.s president in coordination
with his partners and allies to further
inflict
harsh punishment on vladimir putin and
the russian economy
in sorry kimberly just to clarify
you're talking about
the permanent normal trade relations a
repealing of that status
yes that's what i was talking about
let's go on just to clarify for viewers
okay
i'm sorry i'm not sure why you
interjected there but the point i was
trying to make was this is the latest in
the series of punishing actions punitive
actions
by the u.s president coordination with
partners and allies because he did
mention in coordination with other
nations including canada
as well as others in order to inflict
damage on the russian economy and in
other words the trading relationship
which would have a financial impact and
so that is what this latest action is
about
and the us president is making that
announcement and of course this is the
latest in a number of serious actions
this would remove the favored
trading status that russia enjoyed up to
this point and uh this would impact a
number of russian goods vodka for
example so this is again an announcement
that was anticipated and one that the
u.s president has done in coordination
with the west as a result of the russian
invasion of ukraine
all right thanks so much kimberly what
didn't mean to throw you off just wanted
to clarify since we hadn't uh mentioned
we hadn't referenced it yet just to make
sure that viewers knew that we were
talking about the repealing of the
permanent normal trade relations status
which was of course the reason
ostensibly that the u.s president had
appeared
uh to give us uh this talk or this
update let's continue this now would you
like to have with us here on set marwan
bashara he's al jazeera senior political
analyst so looking through the points
which were being made by the u.s
president there
and looking at these statements made
just shortly before that
a coordination of messaging right that
you know we are
we are having real impact on the
russians and the effort to isolate
russia will continue
so you had uh
the american president basically echoing
the french president whose country now
leading the european union for the next
six months
emphasizing two tracks
the american president which is the
humanitarian track helping ukraine
the sanctions track
pressuring russia
both of them saying the sanchez are
working
basically telling journalists and the
public opinion don't don't worry we are
at it
this will hurt russia a lot let's
remember two things one
how formidable
is the west's
economic corporate industrial
technological
arsenal
that it's
basically deploying against russia let's
also remember that russia's economy is
smaller than a medium-sized european
economy like italy it's a small economy
and it could actually hurt and we've
heard some of the evidence but on the
track of the humanitarian
of course
it's very hard to prove
especially with the scenes that we see
every day that the humanitarian effort
is really helping the ukrainians right
right i mean the country is imploding
but just by the way so just to add one
thing
the american president said nothing and
he's been saying nothing from the very
beginning on the diplomatic track the
french president on the other hand
added the third dimension they were
humanitarian sanction and then the
diplomatic saying we will continue to
isolate russia but we want to bring
russia into a diplomatic process so how
do you read the the divergence when it
comes to emphasis on diplomacy at this
point are you saying that there's more
of an appetite to reach a quick
diplomatic solution in europe
it's always been the case from day one
the europeans always believed until
putin basically punched them in the face
that diplomacy could work by going in
with that cigarette but they still
insist
that diplomacy should work because by
the way
the end of any any war is to do business
until and to have peace i mean what are
they what us what's war war so the idea
for the europeans who their feet is
closer to the fire
is to say look there's a war going on we
need to end it we need to have a
diplomatic process because the idea of
the continuation of the war seen from
washington
is basically less feverish less harmful
than for the neighboring european the
east europeans are
not just anxious not just worried they
are scared
and the west europeans are really
solidifying themselves because they are
worried about what putin could do next
but in addition to the three uh tracks
that you mentioned
we also are hearing
the same message being echoed in
washington dc and in versailles about
acting in unison acting together with
allies absolutely the russian attempt as
this is the western narrative the
russian attempt to divide europe to push
nato back is actually backfiring
absolutely look
when putin started
basically saber rattling in east ukraine
there was still a division between the
europeans and the americans but when he
invaded
they mended fences and and nato became
much stronger much more united and the
european union became much more urantic
east and west so basically by invading
ukraine
putin has
delivered back nato into life
knit to the brain dead nato is now back
into life europeans saying we're going
to coordinate among us and of course
coordinate with nato
and of course there are two things we've
heard simon just saw our viewers rick
you know recap what they've heard the
last hour and a half or two hours
there's the me there's the immediate the
humanitarian the sanctions and so forth
but the europeans give us a far more
important picture beyond the immediate
there's the long term
europe is going to look for independence
and sovereignty
europe energy independence energy
depends on sovereignty no but also
independence in general they said we
will cooperate with the world but we
have to be stronger we have to be
stronger defense wise we have to be
stronger economic wise we have to be
independent
in terms of energy in terms of energy
but also
long-term
de-invest from the russian economy
that's probably the most important
message i heard that means it's not just
about sanctions next we heard about 330
companies according to our own website
that already now are leaving or
boycotting ukraine right but the idea
that we're going to punish russians not
only in the short term we're going to
the invest from the russian economy
right on complete disconnection all
right thanks so much marwan bashar